dr anatoly pavlov is filming what's left
of his mikolai of hospital
i want to cry he says in russian his
first language because we had a
connection between ukraine and russia
but russian cruelty is so brutal
nowhere is the cruelty greater than in
the besieged city of maryupo ukrainian
authorities say two more large bombs
were dropped tuesday and at least one
hundred thousand people want to leave
but can't
the mayor of mali topol says like
mariupol his residents are also running
out of food and medicine
[Music]
similar supply struggles reported in
occupied hassan where russian troops
again allegedly used stun grenades to
break up protests
rome the latest virtual venue for
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
describing his country as russia's
gateway to europe
he pleaded with italian lawmakers for a
complete european ban on russian oil and
gas imports
the white house suggesting the eu and
u.s president joe biden will make
further commitments in europe this week
he will announce joint action on
enhancing european energy security and
reducing europe's dependence on russian
gas at long last now
zielinski has told ukrainian media he is
prepared to meet with his russian
counterpart vladimir putin un secretary
general antonia guterres imploring
russia to make that happen and to stop
its invasion
continuing the war in ukraine
is morally unacceptable
politically indefensible
and militarily nonsensical
there is enough on the table to seize
hostilities now
and seriously negotiate now the kremlin
said tuesday it would like the ongoing
talks between teams from russia and
ukraine to be more active and
substantive but it refuses to make
public the demands it's making
jackson redmond shannon in london thanks
redmond